your father saw the worst that mankind
has to offer no question how did he make
a film then that had the universe how
did he respect what he had seen he knew
what the Holocaust meant but he didn't
want to do a night in fog like Ln Rene
he wanted to do something that was
acceptable and accessible for an
American audience how did he bridge what
he knew with what he was trying to
accomplish when we started to work on
the Diary of Anne Frank my father asked
me to come over to 20th Century Fox I
was then working with Jack Webb and
directing Alfred Hitchcock and Peter
Gunn and television and that said would
you like to work with me on the film and
of course I wanted to and he was on the
jury of the Cannes Film Festival that
year and and we went to can it was a
year of that the 400 blows and the
Seventh Seal and these great films but
then we drove to Munich and got up the
next morning went to this little town 30
kilometers from Munich where he hadn't
been since April of 1945 and was Dachau
and we went to the camp where he had
been among the first to enter and filmed
and captured really the evidence on film
of what took place there and it was
extraordinary to be there with my father
at that place and then we went on to
Normandy and went to Juno Beach where he
landed and visited all of those sites
where he and his unit had been after
d-day and then to Amsterdam we went to a
little town I mean little office in
downtown rang the bell that who or was
opened by this tall man with gray hair
very he'd been otto frank had been an
officer in the German army in the first
war and he invited us in and
introduced to us to his wife fritzy his
two daughters of course and his wife had
died at Belsen and we sat and had coffee
and he was looking at the man my father
who was going to tell his daughter's
story and after a moment he stood up and
he walked over and opened a filing
cabinet and brought something down
wrapped in cloth and put it in front of
us and unfolded the cloth and there was
this red plaid book on his diary with
the photographs and her handwriting and
photographs of the movie stars he
admired and then we went to the hiding
place an otto frank took us up to where
the bookcase was and took us to where
they had come to take them away and he
told us the story and he said that they
asked him for the his briefcase and
shook it out on the floor and it had
money and jewelry and it also had all
these papers and they scooped up the
money and they scooped up the jewelry
and they left the papers on the floor
and they left and of course they left
the evidence that was this girl's voice
which would become so much more powerful
over time than their fewers voice